good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
hump day it's wednesday our favorite day
here at the morning toast for a
multitude of reasons one
most likely theo is going to be here on
wednesday because it's hump day and he
is here so that's wonderful
i mean it's we could end the show now
because theo is here
because we've done our job we got our
hot hit of tigs
also a fabulous day because it's dear
toaster segment our weekly advice
segment which
i actually skimmed through fabulous
submissions today like
really funny and interesting and i think
you'll have a hot take on one of them
specifically
okay um and then we also have to recap
the bachelorette so it's just gonna be
like a long juicy interesting show if
you're sitting at work or working from
home and you're just like
damn i wish like one hour would go away
like we're about to do that for you here
magic poof and our after um
our bachelorette segment is called after
dale i just want to normalize calling it
after dale because like
when you said that on last week's show
and then i went in my phone looking for
after nail photos
i was literally laughing so hard someone
made the funniest comment being like i
missed being like one of the nine people
on the live stream
and that's literally where we were at
one time when we did our riverdale after
show after dale
um there was nine people on the live
stream but one of them was the creator
of riverdale
ryder ross so we had to keep doing it um
but we really
it was just it was a weird time that was
such an interesting like time for us
and a project to take on it was like
literally nobody asked but riverdale
this was season two and it was like just
after like the explosive season one we
thought it was like
we thought we were really doing
something and we had this like amazing
set it turned out to be like a torturous
if you're like new here and you have no
idea what after all is
it with our old show we like did a
spin-off called after now and it turned
out to be like such a torturous event
because we would have to
stay in the office at till 9 watch
riverdale from 9 to 10 and then go live
on youtube at 10 30 and like in being
full hair and makeup
with ben and margo and then we're in the
middle of time square and then have to
like get home by 11 and then like go
back to the studio the next morning it
was just like not an
ideal schedule for us yeah like god
forbid someone had sent us screeners
but right so i think after dale is
really emblematic of who we are because
you can see that entrepreneurial spirit
like coming through even when we were
just
technically cogs in a corporate machine
and i think
after dale was technically like our
first tnn show
wow you're right it was the first kind
of expansion like branching out of our
business
yeah that was also such a weird time i
remember getting a phone call from
my agent at the time who represented one
of the girls on the show
um and was like you have to be nicer to
her like we were like she like heard
that you were talking [ __ ] i'm like
literally nine people watch a show like
there's no way this girl heard me say
anything the nine people were just the
cast so like we couldn't stop because we
were like
because the creator of the show was
watching and we were like hating it
and we we can't let him down literally
the creator tunes in
it was just a really tough time um but
some and by the way
it created this like deep resentment for
me of the franchise
yeah no but it's a funny piece of toast
history yeah and
it's just it's hysterical it was me
margo
ben and claudia and we just were
recapping
riverdale on afterdale but now after
dale is this segment of
the bachelorette recap what will happen
after dale
right it used to be the morning rose now
it's just gonna be after dale
yeah no i like after y'all better
because it harks back to our history me
too it's pertinent to the situation
quite pertinent speaking of pertinence
yesterday last night
after um bachelorette i started the
meeting of mariah
finally after i had my moose boosh on
monday i was able to take it on
so good i'm 15 through you were right
it's very
dense and like tight i want to say
what's the word like it's very like each
sentence
has so much like full so much so many
descriptors
so much information in it that it's like
it's kind of a long read and also the
beginning is her story of her childhood
which is also very intense
and so it's a very heavy book and i'm
really really enjoying it it's like
intense stories written through even
more intense sentences
yes and i think that that's what the
story deserves i agree
and i'm really enjoying learning more
about mariah's childhood
and i feel like it definitely is already
affecting like how i see her like i keep
thinking about that new york time
not new york times new year's new year's
eve
performance when she just like got
completely i don't think it was new
year's eve i think it was
the tree lighting at uh rockefeller
center oh yeah because she's christmas
anyways and isn't it interesting like
you totally understand her obsession
with christmas yes
no these sort of things like
everything's just starting to make sense
like christmas is just like emblematic
of like the traditional family and like
growing up that's all she wanted
and now i'm just like thinking back to
those moments like the tree lighting
where
her singing went sort of sideways and
i'm like we need to have more respect
for her i completely this is a woman who
has proven over and over again that she
is one of the greatest singers of our
time so even if she has an off night
like she's still mariah carey yeah
like off put some respect on her name i
agree you're right you're totally new
and like i'm talking to myself too you
know of course like of course i posted
that video like i thought it was crazy
somebody isolated her vocals from the
actual um
track it was just her her voice and it
was like awful
yeah but she deserves some grace like
being in the industry for 30 years and
and really being like having the voice
of an angel and yeah being at the top of
her game vocally
since the time she was 18. it's not like
it was ever a question like is she
really singing
it's not like you know talented award
shows and it's like oh she really can't
sing like you literally go to award
shows and you see the people
who use auto-tune and who genuinely
cannot sing and the people who are just
as talented as they are on itunes as
they are
in person yeah ryan carrey's always been
one of the latter yeah but
but like also on another level like the
whistle
it's just incredible so i look forward
to reading more of that book today
are you a lamb a lamb what's that that's
what she calls her fans
i didn't even know that i hope i can't
wait to get to that part and i get the
lamb thing
and i'm on my way i'm just gonna say
like i really i'm on my way
and i'm excited to finish the book and
then share some of the biggest
bombshells
that i've learned from it yeah when she
was on watch shopping's live she said
like
people i think were shocked at like most
of the book is about her childhood
not about like fame derek jeter even
though that's the stuff that got like
pulled in the press
um because like in order to understand
the meaning of mariah you need to
understand like all that she has been
through
so if you're like me and like your
favorite part of a book is like celeb
juicy
tell-all um you're gonna have to wait a
little bit
that's usually my favorite part too but
i'm realizing
maybe it's just me getting older or
older but we're just reading more that
like
i really do enjoy and get so much
out of like learning about mariah's
childhood learning about her parents
childhood like it's all
part of the fabric of your life and it's
all important and
i i get it a much better sense
of the celebs that i love when i can
understand their childhood
and by the way you can always tell um
through their books like which
celebrities have obviously
been through extensive therapy um
because they place so much emphasis on
like these stories in their childhood
like jessica simpson howard stern mariah
carey
you could just tell from the book that
like therapy is a huge part of their
lives yeah but then also do you ever
feel like there are some people where
it's just like their childhood
like isn't that like i feel like it
could go either way like you know
sometimes like
your childhood is just your childhood
and sometimes like it'll affect you for
the rest of your life
yeah i guess it depends what happens
right and i think it's like no matter
how you grew up or where you grew up
like some people just like
had childhoods that like deeply affected
them and trauma
yeah and some people just didn't yeah
they agreed so
that's exciting that i'm looking forward
to that that's where i'm at right that's
where i'm at mentally today the book
yeah that's great
um mentally i am just here you know
present with my son
feeling strong feeling really excited
about you know the next
couple days because um i got a big
weekend plan i'm we're actually going to
dinner which
these days is like a big weekend planned
it's basically like i'm going to vegas
you know
and i can't be stopped and i can't be
tamed and then we roll right out into
the weekend to tuesday where i feel like
i've never been more excited for
anything in my entire life tuesday i
have
a major announcement now rtk toasters
like might know it already
but i don't want to spoil it i'm going
to like make it into such a big deal
tuesday's going to be such a fabulous
event a fabulous show
and not only do i have like a major
major career milestone
like to share with you it gets better it
does get better but it's all like
wrapped up into one as far as your
special projects secret projects go
this is one that i am so excited about
too and i'm so excited for you
and the countdown to tuesday is on the
countdown
to tuesday is on
okay also i just would be rdh if i
didn't point out the fact that we are
both some turtlenecked queens i know
today
you know i feel like i'm really getting
a lot of my um date like style
inspiration from tick tock and the kids
are wearing tight turtlenecks
that's what i have to do okay well i'm i
i didn't see that and i just i just like
you're just naturally on track every
time i wear this blazer um
that i bought because like lauren
elizabeth had it and i thought it was so
cute i always wear this turtleneck with
it because it was the
turtleneck i was wearing the night that
i tried on her blazer oh they just like
go together
some things just stick with you yeah
they just go better together
and probably always will should we dive
in should we okay i just want to say
before we dive in
um i'm a little like off today i guess
because i forgot my ipad
you know i know i left it charging but i
really did think that i picked it up and
put it in my bag but
i've been having like weird like leaving
the house
problems yeah three days in a row a mask
three days in a row
i left my already made coffee upstairs
in my kitchen and today and monday i
went back for it
but yesterday it was too late before i
remembered so i'm just like
being forgetful wait so if you hear some
like typing
it's because i'm using my computer today
i'm really sorry jackie you and i have
spoken extensively about like
just leaving your ipad here and charging
it here like why don't you do that
um well yesterday specifically i took it
with me because
for my babysitting mission i thought i
might want to watch
um some wild wild country which by the
way i finished
and do not waste your time just like
google the story because i'm sure that's
more interesting
speaking of not wasting your time do not
if you're if you have been
influenced by me to think about starting
to watch the vow don't because you know
what i just found out you're gonna die
they're coming out with a second season
oh my god of a documentary
okay the story is not that good of a
documentary where there's an episode of
american greed on it already so i would
just go straight there
oh and now the story of rajneesh prom
should have been
and maybe it already is an episode of
american green even though it's not like
totally about greed
depends how you look at it um it's just
a
i feel like they could have made it work
there's also now a stars documentary on
it and they actually got
india oxenburg which is pretty cool um i
actually might
watch that in xcm documentary hopefully
they don't drag it out also we did not
talk about but shark tank is back
and do you know who their guests um
shark is who kendra scott the necklace
designer like everyone wears those
little necklaces and she seems really
cool
um and they've been like just putting on
when i was watching the bachelor last
night with abc commercials
it was being promoted so much and their
commercials are so inspiring like
i just want to start my own business and
like watch shark tank at the same time
we need to start re-watching
like keeping up with shark tank yeah
okay i'm down because like that's where
i do some of my best shopping
no i know and interesting i'd love to
learn more about kendra scott
and then also speaking of um abc i put
on my tv at seven o'clock and i watch
jeopardy and wheel of fortune and i just
i think i'm at the place in my life
where i need to make that a part of my
daily
routine like first of all watching
jeopardy just like i got like three
answers i'm not gonna lie
it was um frank lloyd wright because
like it was a question about the
architect and that was literally the
only architect i knew when i screamed
at the tv and it was right and ben was
so impressed then they were talking
about some vegetable like heart and
the only vegetable i know that has a
heart is an artichoke i was also
thinking maybe hearts of palm but i just
went with artichoke
and then the other one was oh it was a
comedian question
um there was a whole uh category of
comedians i don't remember what it was
ben was so impressed and it just like i
don't know it really made me feel like
good and smart and then i went to wheel
of fortune like played with my brain a
little bit
and you know i know it's like shows
reserved ex exclusively for like 70 year
olds but i think that's that's going to
be my vibe moving forward
yeah and i also think that you know this
last year has really aged us
so maybe like we are at like the mental
capacity of like what we want to watch
is what a seven-year-old one
wants to watch a place to call home yes
and jeopardy
get on it and jeopardy i just like i
feel like
jeopardy is it i think i might actually
be like the least qualified person to
like i will i wouldn't there's a million
game shows i could go on i would
actually be excellent at family feud and
i'm pretty good of
wheel of fortune but like i might be the
dumbest person on planet earth like i
will never get onto jeopardy but maybe
if i watch enough episodes like it'll
happen for me and i start at 26
by the time i'm 50 it could happen
exciting things to look forward to so
yes sorry we got a little off track
i think now without further ado it is
time for the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
um yes jackie that is not not true
you know but i think here at the morning
toast it's really important that we put
an emphasis
on the truth i agree and transparency
just like
being open and honest and and raw and
vulnerable
and in in the spirit of that i just
think
i'm trying not to like get choked up um
i have something to say please it's been
a long time coming a lot of people have
wanted me to address this
and i don't know just
feels like the right time okay take all
the time you need
today's episode is brought to you by
nothing new comfortable durable
and sustainable nothing new is proving
that eco-friendly doesn't need to look
eco-friendly nothing new makes the most
fabulous shoes and they're made from
recycled water bottles and 100
sustainable materials so that's recycled
fishing nets
cotton recycled rubber recycled cork the
list goes on
they're designed with comfort in mind so
you never know that you're wearing a
pair of sneakers that's made from like
old water bottles um the name is nothing
new obviously because they're made from
nothing new all their materials are
recycled they come in a bunch of
different styles they have low tops high
top sales so make fabulous socks the
shoes come in like over 15 colors
it's a fabulous product one because you
just like always need like a fabulous
pair of sneakers high tops or low tops
and it's fabulous because you're like
saving the environment by purchasing
a pair of shoes and that feels good
because it costs more to make an
eco-friendly sneaker without the harmful
glues and chemicals
most that most sneakers are made with
nothing new doesn't offer sales or
discounts at this time
but they are giving back to the
environment for our listeners they'll
plant a tree for every pair purchased
so go to nothingnew.com toast that's
n-o-t-h-i-n-g-n-e-w
dot slash toast and try a pair with free
shipping and returns today
and nothing new will plant a tree in a
forest in need so you get a fabulous
pair of shoes and then you get to plant
a tree
that's nothing new dot com slash toast
you have to use that link
and you also get free shipping and
returns if you use that link for a
fabulous pair of shoes
awesome sign on get great shoes first
up word on the street is that sofia
richie has a new
boyfriend let's meet him his name is
matthew morton and the two were spotted
grabbing dinner at nobu
he is is he camilla cabello's
ex-boyfriend no no that's matthew hussey
the dating the love guru
that was like the weirdest time in
camilla cabello's life where she was
like actually dating a nobody
um yeah but matthew morton sofia richie
they just went to nobu so it could have
been like a business dinner
because he is the founder of chacha
matcha but he could also be her rumored
new beau
i'm gonna say something controversial
what you don't like matcha well of
course i think that goes without saying
but i just think that like the franchise
cha-cha matcha
which is a fabulous name it's just like
the most unnecessary institution
on the face of the earth do you know
what i mean it's like they sell matcha
at starbucks or
i assume they do i don't know i've never
ordered it but they sell it at like
every place
and i just think like having its own
dedicated chain is like a level of
privilege like i just can't relate to do
you know what i mean no
i i really really do but like this the
na the name is so cute of the story and
the story is
so cute you just want to go there and
take pictures proud to say i've never
done that but like that's also just
because i don't really live close to one
i don't know and i feel like we have
listeners who have literally never heard
of cha cha matcha and like i'm actually
envious of that life experience like i
i don't know how i got myself into a
place where like i'm constantly being
bombarded by like
cha cha machan is yeah and i want
nothing to do with it like yeah
i think that like as a brand i am the
antithesis of cha cha matcha
yeah like if they opened like a
competitor across the street
it'd be you and it was like mcdonald's
and we would literally
just sell like flurry soda and
milkshakes yeah
yeah no i i feel that for you um and i
just couldn't
eat it because i completely agree okay
i'm glad and cause like it's not even
that i'm like an unhealthy person and
which i am
i'm not denying that and i don't think
that there's no need for like a healthy
cafe i think it's fabulous
but like to have an entire brand
identity be associated with like
matcha it's just
it's so unnecessary and you know we're
living in crazy unprecedented times
and i feel like people are really
prioritizing like what's important to
them and i just don't think matcha is
and maybe i'm wrong you guys will
obviously let me know but i don't know i
think i'm i think i'm hitting the nail
on the head with this one i just think
you're speaking to like a lot of people
and you're you're also offending a lot
of people
and you know what i just and that's what
you do that is so me
and i don't know i just don't have like
a good feeling that like our audience is
like huge matcha fans i just feel like i
know our brand and i just think like
we're on the right side of history in
this one yeah i i feel you as well um
but apparently sophia richie likes her
matcha oh i believe she's only dating
him just to get the free matcha because
you know what matcha is expensive
matcha it's very expensive also it's
expensive grass
this story hurts my heart a little bit
because it means like that maybe scott
and sophia are done for real this time
and i just i ship them completely i will
ship them
i'll i'll sail around the world in my
ship you're captain sandy
yeah but of an empty vessel yeah
nobody's on board nobody's on board
that's so sad
mayday nobody's on board it's just me
and one cup of matcha
wow that sounds like a bad time that's
what i'm saying
so sorry who's dating oh yes sofia
richie and this man
but it's only because they were spotted
out at nobu once and now i'm starting to
like be really skeptical about nobody
there's some will you follow me on this
100 because the kardashians are always
there
and they're always getting photographed
there and so they know that if they go
there they're going to get photographed
they wear their best looks with a
matching mask
they bring their friends and their best
cars because you get paparazzi at the
valet
it's a place to see and be seen it's
like the racetrack everybody's going to
be up in your business 100
so i have to question sofia richie as a
kardashian extension knows that this is
what goes down at nobu malibu and so
she's either like wanting everyone to
think she's in a new relationship
or it's like not an actual like if it
was like a real treasured
you know blossoming blooming
relationship like i don't think you
would step out to nobu malibu just
mere weeks after a serious relationship
ended which makes me believe
that this is not a serious relationship
okay that's true but let me offer just
one
brief rebuttal you're totally right but
nobu malibu was also the most delicious
and fabulous restaurant
and maybe she just couldn't resist i i
hear that but maybe she wanted a premium
dining experience with a premium view
and a premium setting and a premium vibe
and this was the price she had to pay
for that experience oh maybe two things
to say to that one like she could have
done
take out two not the same two i do think
there are other places in malibu
that are um for celebrities that are
extremely private
with good food too and on the water yeah
no and i just want to say like
there is a a way i hate to be like such
like a name dropper but i just want to
pull on some personal experience
to let you know that like if a celebrity
doesn't want to be seen
they don't have to be seen like what
would you say in la proper like his most
fabulous restaurant
star-studded craig's okay so i was at
craig's
with a very very famous person now i
don't want to be a name dropper but it
was kate beck and sale
we were having an amazing time we were
with another friend and he was going to
stay and she was like do you want to
drive you home like i have a car
and i'm like oh my god fabulous we're
going to walk out together like
literally
there's 50 paparazzi who just stand
outside craig's
and she was like come with me and i'm
like oh my god not only am i going to
get to drive home with her like i'm
going to be paparazzi like maybe she'll
like
show me off to the pops of course we go
out the back entrance and we're in like
a car that has like umbrellas covered
all over it and like we never were seen
by anyone
so the most even at the most fabulous
restaurant in la like
you can be in and out without being seen
so if you want to go to nobu and not be
seen i
guarantee you there's a way there's a
private room there's a back entrance
there's something i'm just saying
you pull up on your boat from the back
like there's there are ways to be to do
things
yeah there is not a there's not a dock
or a port no i didn't want to share that
because they do not chip
you know that it pained me to be such a
name dropper like and i didn't want to
share
you know that personal experience
because i just i hate to be that person
you guys know i'm like so not like that
but it's germaine to the situation it's
so
pertinent to the situation that i just i
had to call upon my personal experience
i'm sorry i won't do it again
it's okay i mean until the next time
it's germaine to the situation
no it helps add color to the story yeah
no i'm i'm nothing it's not like a
colorful storyteller
that's actually very true thank you okay
speaking of fame nicole kidman says
fame was says fame when she was single
was
much harder so nicole kidman
um was speaking with the sydney morning
herald in a recent interview and the
actress told the publication that she
thinks fame
was much harder for her when she was
single because there wasn't a shield
there wasn't a place to go and to work
through it with a partner she said
before she noted how she would lean on
others to be her safeguard including her
sister
love to see it nicole kidman had a
sister antonia
oh i like that name i was lucky because
my sister would come i remember her
flying to cannes in 2001 because it's
frightening walking up that red carpet
with all that security feeling very
insecure
and not quite sure where to go or how to
survive
nicole who recently celebrated her 14th
wedding anniversary with husband keith
urban continued to detail her connection
with her sister
if you have a sister as a woman it's
such a blessing because there's this
closeness where you can really delve
into one into another woman
with safety we're almost twins and we've
been through a lot
i just like love this sister
appreciation moment i love the sister
appreciation moment i love that like
she went from being you know single and
obviously struggling with the fame to
now being
what i perceive to be like the most
fabulous healthy marriage of all time
we're like they're both successful and
supportive of one another's dreams and
they live in nashville in a palace and
they probably have a farm with a goat
and i just think like what more can you
ask for the most precious woman on earth
nicole kidman no you you really can't
ask for much more and to know that she
has a sister
like behind every great woman there's a
sister who like completely loves and
supports everything that she does
that is so true and you know what
normalize changing that awful state like
um
phrase behind every great man there's a
greater woman
two behind every great woman there's a
greater sister i just think it's better
it's more appropriate
yeah and you know what i think that
sisterhood is just so beautiful
and i love like a publication the sydney
herald is that what it is
i love a publication that highlights and
appreciates sisterhood
yeah and like i'm sure there was a lot
of tea in this interview with nicole
kidman and that like they chose to focus
on like the bond of sisterhood
beautiful what's that from the bonds of
sisterhood i have no idea
but claudia that's beautiful oh it's
from legally bond of course when victor
garber is um
like making fun of her for not sharing
brooks
which i just have to say i know she won
the case without it
but it was a little silly it was but
like to me yes of course she could have
shared the alibi
everyone could have gone home but
knowing that your client has an airtight
alibi
you know that they are innocent
so when when elle says like we wouldn't
be very good lawyers
if we can't get her off knowing that she
didn't do it knowing for sure that she
didn't do it yes okay
i meant it was kind of silly of ali
larter
screw sisterhood that is what he said
um it was a little silly of brooke
windham
bronwyn wyndham burke it was a little
silly of her to
not want to tell people she got
liposuction and possibly go down for
manslaughter like that was silly
yeah like i know you have a reputation
to uphold who would you rather be a
fraud or a murderer
well she hired the best in the midst so
like she thought she had a third option
which by the way
she did you only get one chance at trial
you don't like
juggle and take a gamble on whether or
not like just tell her when you got
liposuction
well for her i was juggling and taking
gambler with her career
yeah and she said i would rather rot in
prison than spend the rest of my life
whatever you know she said that thing
yes she said it she said what she said
oh also by the way
yesterday as promised on our instagram
we posted a not a full list but an
introductory list to what we consider to
be some of the greatest content uppers
of all
times which is basically just movies
that are funny fun will make you laugh
they're not too serious they have a
great cast they have great music
it's just a small introduction to
content uppers which is something we've
been talking about a lot during these
unprecedented times
it's never been more necessary to have
content that ups you
and so check out our instagram at the
morning toast we recently got verified
and i'm very excited about it i just
want to plug it
check it out okay next story kim
kardashian settles a 6.1 million
lawsuit with the security company from
her paris robbery oh my god
i didn't know we were still playing this
out no me neither kim has secretly
settled a 6.1 million
lawsuit with the security company that
quote failed to protect her
during her devastating robbery in paris
according to the sun
pascal yes exactly in october 2016 as we
know kim was tied up and put in the
bathtub of her hotel room
by five armed robbers who had posed as
cops to gain entry
they left with 10 million dollars worth
of jewelry including a 5 million
diamond ring from her husband kanye her
bodyguard
pascal duvier had left her alone in the
room while he escorted her sisters
courtney and kendall to the club
according to the british paper kim filed
pascal and then sued him in his company
for negligence
but reps for kim have not responded to
the story so it's like still a secret
so pascal owes kim kardashian six
million dollars his
security hit the security company that
either he works for or he owns
yeah no it's like a part of me is like
yeah
why did he leave her alone but at the
same time it's like why did three of the
most famous women on earth only have one
security guard
yeah kim shouldn't have been left alone
but what we're kindling
and courtney's supposed to go alone to a
club yeah they need more security and
you know what i feel like that's what
they took away from this like their
houses are fortresses and it's so sad
that like something so traumatic had to
happen in order for them to like take
their security so seriously i feel like
their security is literally like
a character on the show like they're
always talking about like the gates and
the secret security guards and the
cameras
um i just can't believe that like now
how what year was this in
this was 2016 2016.
um four years later yeah like we're
still litigating but that's how
that's how litigation works yeah who and
i
like you said yesterday she talks about
it on the letterman
um i believe so it'll be interesting to
hear more if she chooses to talk about
it and if she doesn't
we understand yeah i think the letterman
is out today it said wednesday but i
don't know if it was next wednesday or
this wednesday
dates are confusing by the way in these
unprecedented times dates are so
confusing
okay next story a little exciting news a
little exciting branding news
bravo debuts the first official real
housewives wine collection
oh this seems like a no-brainer yeah
bravo is now only recently like getting
on the bandwagon
of like let's make money on the
housewives when all the house guys are
making money on us
you know real housewives fans have seen
their fair share of wine throwing
incidents over the course of 14 years
and a multitude of franchises
and finally there's an official wine
made specifically to sip on
while you watch the wines which are made
in partnership with knocking point wines
in washington state come in three
varieties
the real house red the real house white
and the real house rose
that's cute yeah wait knocking point
wine sounds familiar is that the same
company that did
witches of weho wine i'll look it up i
believe that it is knocking
point one which would just be
interesting if like stassi kristen and
katie like set the precedent for like
all of the bravo wine partnerships it's
just something interesting to think
about and i think that they did
yes it was knocking point yeah which is
interesting this is a great idea i mean
it's going to do great i'm glad that
bravo only recently has bravo kind of
started to monetize their fan base in a
sense like i feel like
since the first episode of housewives
the housewife themselves have started to
capitalize monetize books
shows other tv shows like they've
started to
create fandoms and make money off of
their audience but bravo only recently
like started to do bravocon
and really kind of capitalizing on their
cult following and i think this is like
the next step in that direction and it's
very smart
yeah for sure i agree i think it's smart
and
like we said a no-brainer i think the
bachelor also did something similar
right yeah and these are like limited
limited special
editions yeah for the super fans so if
you want one go and get it i don't think
it'll be around long yeah the bachelor's
been good about that like over the years
like doing like
different like events or podcasts like
they kind of lean into it
yeah whereas like bravo like all these
women do their own podcast having
nothing to do with bravo whereas like if
bravo had a podcast network
where they gave all of their cast mates
a podcast and some of them have very
successful ones
don't give them too many good ideas
because like that's an amazing idea
and that is direct conflict with tnns
yeah cause then margaret joseph would
have to leave
yeah check out caviar dreams tuna fish
budget with margaret joseph's now
available anywhere you find your podcast
i love margaret joseph me too did you
see that they're actually making a lot
of progress on her house
yes i cannot wait it looks so good i
feel like so many people in quarantine
like let their lives just like slip away
but marge has
been she's in charge taking care of
everything she's been putting off and
her house looks so good it's like such a
unique like mod colorful
palette and i'm really into it um our
fifth story is something
yeah my um's are just getting out of
control sorry i'm working on them it's
okay
our fifth story is some exciting tv
reboot news that
that people have actually asked for okay
mtv cribs reboot has been announced
with celebrity guests caitlyn jenner
jojo siwa christine quinn and rupaul
drag races alyssa edwards
okay i just have to say of all those
people i have already seen alyssa
edwards house she did architectural
digest and was very shocking because you
don't expect like this fabulous
um drag queen to live in like a
cul-de-sac in a suburban neighborhood
like she just literally lives on like
wisteria lane it's very interesting
i've seen jojo siwa's house because she
has a youtube channel i think honestly
mtv cribs like
might have missed the mark because while
it's fabulous i've literally seen
everyone's house tour and everyone has
seen our house tours like it's just
house tours on youtube as a trend
architectural digest now does that like
73 questions you see people's houses
like wow they're a little late wow this
is a hot take i wasn't expecting
no but like i mean for me that like this
is a story because of christine quinn
and i don't know
her like i honestly wouldn't have sought
it out as a story i'm dying to see her
house
i think that she's an amazing choice but
i do agree that like when they're
choosing
celebrities who are influencers or
digital celebrities there's a good
chance we've already gotten a house tour
from them
and so i'm down for the idea of mtv
crips and i was actually just thinking
about cribs while reading mariah carey's
book because i remember her episode of
mtv cribs
so distinctly she showed her a new york
city penthouse and like it was when we
were so so young
and i even remembered when she was in
her shoe closet talking about how
growing up she like only had one pair of
shoes
and it was just all coming back to me
and i think that mtv cribs they do
they do not only great house tours but
like the whole production the stories
and everything is so so good and they
invented like fridge culture
but they should be having on celebrities
who we typically do not have access to
especially in the digital space i agree
because in a lot of ways in the digital
space they've totally missed the mark
like they should have brought back mtv
cribs as a youtube series
five years ago and the fact that they
didn't is such a like a mistake on their
part
and now if they're bringing it back like
in a real way and they're only
highlighting people whose houses we've
already seen it's so silly yeah no
like show me the home of and by the way
i love nicole kidman
right i know i love alyssa edwards i do
but like when you said rupaul
drag race no show me rupaul's house show
me that world of wonder money like
that's something i would never see on
youtube
yeah yeah no i i agree with your take
and you've changed my mind well that
literally never happens i'm just on one
today i'm very excited oh we're gonna do
the bachelorette yeah or
also to show like even caitlyn jenner um
i'm sure her house is amazing but we've
seen a lot of videos
like i am cute so it has to be someone
who doesn't have a youtube presence who
does not have a reality show no it
really has to be like
traditional celebrities ie tv and movie
stars
yeah like who don't have youtube
channels who might not even have
instagram
right which is very rare because like
even most youtube stars
have youtube i mean most tv stars have
youtube channels
yeah true um okay let's dive into our tv
recap segment which is the bachelorette
i have
so many thoughts on last night's episode
and i knew i needed to pull up my
thoughts and i know that you and i
actually really disagree on
one big thing but let's just go
chronologically through the episode
though i watched your story and i think
once again you were maybe changing my
mind
okay because last night's episode was
very strange i feel like i really
started out with this positive head
space where like
i know like claire was kind of a
controversial pick but the more i got to
see her i don't know i was just like
excited about the episode i feel like in
a lot of ways
i i love that she's 39 i don't think it
makes the show any worse if anything it
makes the show better like to have a
grown woman who can speak
real full sentences this is what we said
last week yeah i i'm attracted to her
strengths
yes and then i just feel like with every
second that passed like
that excitement and admiration and
respect i had for claire like
truly was just like a downward spiral
into rock bottom
yeah i mean for me i think it's really
her achilles heel like that she's so so
strong it's amazing and it makes it so
enjoyable to watch but then like
she's a little too strong about she's
certainly too intense yeah and she
very like what like you said on your
instagram story she kind of crosses over
into this teacher mode where it's like
we understand that you're like so
correct and and you're writing your
convictions but like
to demand perfection of everyone like
it's off-putting
oh so i got a dm really quickly i don't
want to get off track but i've been
saying teacher a lot and people
um we have a lot of teacher trusters who
i absolutely love and respect and i just
i need to say i don't mean it in a
negative way
when i say teacher and i was trying to
explain it to this girl but i wasn't
doing a good job when i see teacher it's
like people who are like won't choose a
winner and like you're all winners
that's like such a teacher answer
claire was like literally like looking
for inconsistencies in people's answers
just so she could like call them out
like she was a professor like
making sure you did their homework i
didn't teach you in any negative way i
think that you didn't i think it's just
like this
the relationship between a teacher and
student should not be the same
relationship between boyfriend and
girlfriend okay thank you like
you're so much more articulate than me
sorry to get off track yes
so i just felt like like it's the
relationship between camper and
counselor
yes there were like four or five women
campers last night there were four or
five moments that i just felt like
claire was so unreasonable and that's a
lot for one episode
the first was i thought that that and i
know she hasn't planned the dates but i
thought that one-on-one with that cutie
whose
name of course i don't know where they
had to write the things down
burn the dress talk about their trauma
it's like this is date one this is and i
know that things are definitely
expedited in the bachelor world
but it was just like a little intense it
was too intense and to expect someone
who you just met to open up to on that
level on tv
and i feel like she would have been
disappointed in him if she if he hadn't
done that
i just thought that was wholly
unreasonable i yeah i totally agree and
also for the viewer watching through the
lens of like she has
tunnel vision for dale it is so unfair
for her to like want this man to open up
like
because we know that she really is kind
of giving him half a shot 100
and i thought it was like extremely
intense too intense for a first date two
intense for television and like
he he definitely met her expectations i
think and he like def
there's obviously a lot of a lot to this
man um
but even if he hadn't like i wouldn't
have blamed him my second moment where
claire
really let me down was the tantrum she
threw about the awkward silence
now what happened i think was that the
cocktail party had started and
i think in in the past the second she's
like done with her toast they all clamor
can i grab and there was maybe you know
an extra second taken
and it was awkward which awkward
silences are terrible but it's a
group of nine relative strangers like
awkward silences are definitely bound to
happen
um and then that guy of course i don't
remember his name
did
bennett did ask to talk to her like a
few seconds later than she had wanted
and not only did she completely
disregard him because she was so mad she
ditched the only guy who had actually
expressed interest in talking to her she
literally got up in the middle because
she wasn't listening and then went to go
reprimand a bunch of dudes
for literally not jumping fast enough
it's just it's
and i hate to say this because yes
claire is a strong powerful woman but
like
she's a little unreasonable and kind of
insufferable like and i can't imagine
wanting to be in a relationship with
someone
who's that particular yeah no i agree
with that and i also feel like
this is claire's fifth time on the show
like she knows how it works this is
these guys first group date like they
don't know that the minute the toast is
over
that that's when you ask for her hand
like oh and by the way if they didn't
know that if they didn't know exactly
how the show worked
something would have went off in her
brain be like why do these guys know how
to act so well in the show how many
episodes have they watched
because she's so in her own [ __ ] head
no i totally agree and i understand why
she
probably felt a little awkward because
no one jumped for her hand but like she
has to realize all of these guys are
there for her
sure some aren't but like most of them
really are they're
taking time out of their lives even
though like who wouldn't want to be
there right now right
so for her to like question it so much
like not be
able to let it go and i and i like how
she says she needs to give voice to her
feelings or else they
fester and whatnot but there's also
something to be said for letting
something go
there's also something to be said for
just like social decorum you can be
really mad about something but if this
guy
is now getting to talk to you you
haven't spent a lot of time with him to
literally cut him off mid-sentence and
leave him there so you could go yell at
the other dudes like that's just not
appropriate
social behavior and when you like really
look into it like i just feel like she
was upset with dale for
not being the first person now the dale
of it all is really interesting because
she's saying a lot of things about dale
that
we've never heard a lead say being like
oh my mind is with dale i can stop
thinking about dale
we're hearing her say a lot of those
things and i just thought it was really
interesting that i pointed out is that
she's saying all those things and you're
not seeing her say them they're dubbed
in voice-overs because she didn't
actually say them there
but because it wouldn't she's not
allowed to say stuff like that but i
think when they decided to
end the season and then whatever they
end up doing and the turn that it takes
they now could lean into the storyline
of her being so obsessed with dale
so she would be doing interviews and you
would be seeing her speak and then when
she would say something like really
particular about dale
it would be a voice over that's really
smart i wasn't watching closely enough
to pick up on stuff like that i was
really like on my phone
so much while watching there's just like
a few people who i picked my head up for
dale blake moines yes we need to talk
about
and um and i think that's it actually
so the third thing that happened that
kind of like put me off um on the claire
on the clairvoyance was the next group
date of
dodgeball yes now
i for those who don't know it was a game
of dodgeball and claire had the idea to
make it strip dodgeball so that
there were two teams and whatever team
lost the first round took their shirts
off second round took their
socks off third round took their shorts
off and they were wearing like tiny
little jock straps like basically thongs
um and i i mean i hate to be that person
because i don't know if this is like
such a lame thing to say but like
of course it felt very strange watching
it because you couldn't help but wonder
like
if the gender roles were reversed like
they would literally never let a
bachelor be like let's play strip
volleyball but then you think of the
other
on the other side it's like the girls on
the bachelor are always like being put
in bikinis and bikinis are essentially
naked so it's like
i don't know where i stand like on the
equality of it all but i just know that
watching it
was really made me feel uncomfortable it
felt like
not even like they were objectifying the
men but like embarrassing them almost to
a point
and i just didn't like it and there was
only one guy there forget it was it
blake who had like a normal reaction
being like
why am i like being embarrassed like
okay it's one thing to lose dodgeball
just have to show you my nuts like
yeah it was just very strange and then
her asking the losing team who was
walking out naked like for hugs like
the whole thing felt very off to me yeah
very wrong i agree that there is a level
of
sexualizing the cast that happens on
both sides
but a bathing suit and being fully nude
are totally different without
an option like it made me really
uncomfortable even when they were
playing dodgeball and like just jock
straps and they were like falling on the
floor and stuff and it's like
their bits are like hanging out with
their legs in the air like it was
so so uncomfortable and that's not
acceptable
no and i hate to be like a weenie and
like be that girl but like i don't know
it just like i kind of felt bad for some
of them like
okay not everyone and don't get me wrong
there's definitely a bunch of thir
sponsors on there who were very excited
to be naked and like thought it was
funny
but they're probably just like nice
hamish guys there who like literally
like their families watch the show and
like they just
didn't intend to like show their nuts
yeah and i thought that them wearing the
jobs traps was like really crazy but
then the fact that they like took them
off and then were like walking around
just like
fully nude i i think it's wrong
yeah it just it gave me really weird
vibes and like i don't know claire it
was
i don't know if it was edited this way
but it was made to seem like it was
claire's idea and like she was the one
like living for it like then asking them
all for hugs like
i don't know it it really made me feel
really weird yeah no i agree
i was not here for it and then the
fourth thing that
shook up my night is the one thing i
think you and i might have disagreed on
um and probably was
the most cringey part of the episode was
after that date at the cocktail
she's talking to that guy brandon who
according to my research is like a
lovely jewish
real estate agent from ohio i know okay
never mind
um and i thought he was cute and he was
just like nervous and like trying to
talk and
they slipped into like a really
uncomfortable conversation where he
essentially said and correct me if i'm
recalling it wrong he said you know i'm
so excited to be here when i found out
that you were the best
like i applied immediately like i just
thought you were saying i had to come
yeah i had to come i thought you were so
beautiful
um and she was like oh my god really
like well first he said i had to come i
found out you're about right i had to
come she's like oh my god really like
what about me
made you have to come back sorry it all
started when he said tell me like a
little bit about you i feel like i don't
know that much about you like i know
you're from san francisco no no no
this is what happened i watched it all
like a train wreck in front of me
he said you know i and i guess he was
like he told us in his interview before
that like he didn't have time with her
and he was like really excited to make a
good impression he had a lot of like
riding riding on this conversation yeah
so he said
um i was so excited when it was you like
i'm here because it was you i was so
excited i had to come
and she said oh what was it about me and
he said well you know you're so
beautiful and then it became
like clear that he didn't really know
that much about her but so he said but i
don't know that much about you please
tell me mm-hmm like he wanted her that's
he wanted her to be that to be a jumping
off point for them to like start
letting each other know about each other
but claire saw like the
fallacy in the part that where he said
that he came for her but then didn't
know anything about her
and she was like offended that he might
have come for her only because
he thought she was beautiful not that
she knew anything about her insides and
it was just so first of all i thought
the way that she acted
let's say she had this realization i
think the way she spoke to him was so
condescending and like the way she just
like shuttled him out
like literally ended the conversation
like can i walk you out i thought it was
so rude and like so disrespectful for
someone who literally put their life on
the line and quarantined for a month
two weeks at home and two weeks for you
in in palm springs i thought it was such
a rude way to
like shatter someone out and the way she
reacted was literally like he said like
he literally called her like a name like
i just thought it was incredible
overreaction
and i actually really like on a season
of the bachelorette
where the girl is in the middle of a
date and like knows that it's not right
and doesn't want to waste their time and
caitlin bristol used to do that a lot
and actually have a lot of respect for
people who do that who are like
in a nice way like you know what i know
you have a life back home and i don't
want to waste your time i just like feel
like there's no connection here like
i think you should go home i actually
think in the long run that's the nicer
thing to do
um but that's not what this was it was
so rude and i
and honestly i'm trying to get into her
mind of like what she was most upset
about
and i wasn't it wasn't that she wasn't
he was only there for her looks that's
not why she was upset
she was upset because she she thought
and she kind of did catch him in a lie
because what he said about coming here
for her he's only here because it's her
was untrue because he doesn't know
anything about her how do you know
anything about
well other people would be from watching
the seasons so what does she want a guy
who studied
all the seasons this is a guy who
studied bachelor winner games bachelor
paradise one bachelor in paradise two
one pablo season a guy who studied all
of that
knows everything about her has a fan
club about claire and then comes with a
journal with a scrapbook of all the
pictures he loves of her
what it's she's so unreasonable no
here's what she wants she doesn't need
all of that but if you're not
claire's number one fan you don't come
you don't start with i'm here because
it's you because i was so excited for
you
when you don't know her like i don't
think there's anything wrong with it
like
who got cast as the bachelorette like
you know what i actually think
we might work like she's a similar age
to me she's from sacramento and she's
beautiful
like those are the baseline things when
you meet someone before you go on a date
with anyone
where are you from what do you look like
what do you do like that's literally all
you know about it
he's not from sacramento he might be who
[ __ ] knows no but he would like
i think the way that he framed it up he
she didn't have she's trying to
i know but she thought she caught him in
a lie and then like just saw right
through him and was like you're not here
for me you're just saying the things you
think it wasn't that deep
no but it wasn't that i agree with you
but i'm saying like that's where she was
coming from it wasn't that she
set him up it's not that she needs
someone who's watched every season who
knows everything about her already
but don't pretend like you know her
before you do and then it becomes clear
that you don't pretend
they're on tv they have conversations i
don't know i i didn't pretend he knew
anything about her
when i saw it was you i was excited and
i signed up i think it was meant to be a
compliment a flattery and that's it and
i think when
she's so in her own head she's going to
be her own device i think when he said
that that that was untrue
whoever it was he was going to be there
and that's what she thought too because
there's nothing about her that would
have made him want to come other than he
wants to come on the bachelorette
and she really like maybe there's now an
age appropriation
he's 28 years old so he slipped up
she saw it and then she saw like what
could potentially be the worst thing
about like the worst about him which is
like he's just saying what she thinks
she wants to hear
because he wants to be here for this
that and the other thing and when you
are the bachelor you are extremely
on edge that like everybody is here just
to use you and be on television because
a lot of them are
so yes her paranoia came through she
didn't give this guy a chance who
and like who might actually be a good
guy but he led
with like a a statement that was just
like a platitude that was not true
because it was what she wanted to hear
and i actually don't i don't like people
who just say stuff to say it
even when there's nothing to back that's
television baby like that's literally
what this show is like
oh this journey i'm feeling lovely well
then i fly better
yeah you're gonna lie better i just did
not think it was that deep at all i
thought she was being really like nasty
and rude to a guy who was
just seemingly like trying to make
conversation it really wasn't that deep
it gave off the vibe that she's like
deeply insecure and like paranoid and it
actually
might end up like being her demise and
you know what she has a little bit of
nerve to be so hard on like a perfectly
nice guy when she very well knows that
her mind is already made up like
you're not actually considering any of
the other guys here so to embarrass this
guy
when you're gonna end up embarrassing
all them because you already know who
you want to go home with like
i just thought it was really i thought
it was rude it really rubbed me the
wrong way and that was like the nail in
the coffin where
she was rubbing me the wrong way the
whole episode and then
that and i was like oh this is not gonna
work for me because
it's just none of these relationships
have any
hope yeah except for david it didn't rub
me so wrong so i think i saw what she
would like that's her worst fear like
real and that's any bachelor's worst
fear someone's coming on to be on the
show to be famous and literally gives
not a [ __ ] about you
and two am i going to get that vibe from
him at all i know like i did he was
trying to talk and he was nervous on tv
he was nervous on tv but he said
something
like he led with a lie i don't of all
the guys there he just like never gave
me the vibe that he wants to like sell
tea on instagram like
and he very well may end up doing that
because you know opportunity knocks and
you open the door
but i like of all the guys he was just
like a quiet nice guy like i literally
didn't think anything of it and when he
started to call her out i also didn't
get the vibe that he was like a dick and
he was like being defensive
and you know what he could have been a
lot more rude to her when he watched she
was like can i walk you out i would have
been like no get the hell on my way i'm
going home like
he could have been a lot rude to her and
the fact that he wasn't i think proves
that he's just like still like a nice
hamish guy i do think that he is
a nice person and she probably let the
wrong like she definitely read into it
too much
and let a good guy go but she's just
like
she's so because she's i guess of her
age and her strength and maturity like
she's so matter of fact matter of fact
and like
militaristic about everyone acting right
and so when they don't it's over and i
think that that
and i think that while in some instances
it's a great quality
i think it it's a double-edged sword and
that's what you're seeing
i also just think like her bar for
appropriate behavior
it's just like insanely commanding
perfection of everyone every statement
that they say has to be completely
true and genuine and which is like yes
things you say should be true and
genuine but like
to react like that when they're not it
could have just been an awkward
conversation she couldn't let him go at
the rose ceremony
right no one would be the wiser but like
to have to be like so
like right and you know i i hear what
you're saying i don't feel so strongly
that like
as strongly as you i doubt it because i
i kind of saw
where she's coming from but yeah the way
she went about it was all wrong and i
the only other thing i want to talk
about was
blake mointz coming to the i love him
coming to the group date even though he
lost and like
i i feel like it was a great move
because i love him but like if it was
any other
character i would have been like get
this guy out of here and i actually feel
like when he did it
claire did not respect the decision i
agree kind of rude to him but then she
went back and like thought about how she
should feel about it and she has to be
consistent
and then she like had to undo like
turning him
down and so she gave him the rose then
in there because like that's the kind of
man she does think that she wants she
just like
didn't like it in that moment yeah by
the way i totally agree um
i i thought she was definitely gonna
yell at him but then like i think she
just had to be consistent and
she'd yelled enough people for one night
like she had to go be nice to blake
and he's just so like pathetic and sweet
and like i just want him to be happy and
he just like likes claire and like she
literally doesn't even know his name
because
when he showed up i think that she
thought he was someone else at first
because it's
there's so many guys at this point no
but she really likes him she he got the
first rose at the
on the first night after dale yeah and
that's always the person like i think
lauren bushnell got that wrong she
didn't get the first impression where
it's like
that is always the person that you you
should look out for yeah okay that's
interesting but i also i'm like worries
for him now because obviously like she's
all in on dale and he's going all in on
her so when tasha arrives
how is he going to pick up he's and so
he's just going to be like always
claire's runner up
yeah um agreed when teisha arrives a lot
of these dudes are going home but
honestly claire
barely has a connection with any of them
that i actually think there'll be a lot
of guys for who are going to stick
around for t-shirts you know 100 i just
don't know how
blake could i keep wanting to get on
blair how blake could make that
pivot also i think claire is also
rubbing a lot of the guys the wrong way
i think we see that with yo safe and
i know people don't like him but i
definitely understand his frustration
with claire like because she is acting
like a little
mean um is he the one who says
you're the oldest okay then he's a dick
i think we still don't have coffee we
don't know who it is but he's a dick if
he says that um
but i think that a lot of the guys are
just like
they feel like they literally haven't
spoken to claire they have no connection
they're jealous of her connection with
dale
and they maybe don't like like being
yelled at all the time and then like
embarrassing and i think that when
taesha comes like a lot of them will
actually be excited and want to stay
yeah it's not like so many of them have
connections already i do also think that
the first few episodes are always slow
and with the group like we don't even
know who these guys are she barely does
in the beginning they are there like
just being friends and playing dodgeball
and having drinks
by you know six or seven episodes in
like things to start to get serious
but i feel like they never got to that
point because one
she is so in on dale and two because
they don't have all the regular
distractions right of the usual bachelor
seats in the house the trips
laying by the pool like all together and
so everyone's just like really focused
on like
oh we have no connection with her it's
like so early usually they're still
distracted
and the dates are just like pathetic
like that indoor rec room they were
first playing dodgeball at was just like
made me want to cry i'm sorry the date
where they had to do their love like
and like speak up to her while she's
standing on a balcony like romeo and
juliet
like to do something like that week one
where they have to like affirm their
love verbally to claire right they
literally just met her
like to me that's not genuine and if
she's the claire who also doesn't want
to hear that i'm here for you even
though i don't know you
why do you want to hear all these nice
things from guys who also don't know you
right and that's to me like the fatal
flaw
with the bachelor and bachelorette
franchise is that
yes you know who you're going for and
most of the guys definitely like claire
and like want to be with her
some of them are there for fame but it's
very possible and i feel like it doesn't
happen enough where like you meet the
person like you're just not into them
and it's like
i feel like the only time i ever ever
remember that happening is when becca
tilly left chris soul season she was
like
no i just like don't like you and it's
like you just the fact that you
go on a show expect and you don't really
know the person at all on a personal
level
and you're just expected to fall in love
with them like sometimes you just don't
like the person and like where's that
where's that experience that never
happens
yeah it happened a little bit and it
just doesn't air
but i also think like with becca tilly
like she was his runner-up like if you
know you don't like him like
make that known sooner yeah that's true
um i don't know i just
that's the always thing missing i got
really heated with that clear thing
sorry i kept like talking over here i
just like really um
okay you feel strongly i do i'm just
like i love to see passion about the
bachelor like usually we can't even
think of like
no i mean and you know what it's crazy
that i even have this much to say
because last night's episode was truly
one of the worst two hours of television
in my life like
time was moving like maple syrup like
so chunky and slow i don't know if that
makes any sense yeah i just kept looking
at my phone it was like 8 30 8 45.
oh my god it was rough i feel you i do
um so let us know your thoughts i would
love to hear what everyone has to think
and that was our tv recap segment and
now it is dear toasters and i'm very
excited to dive into these
dear toasters if you're new here um
which i know so many of you are like
we're just getting like millions and
millions of new listeners every day it's
like it's honestly exhausting like to be
so popular um so and just like have to
explain everything that i do it's really
difficult
um dear toasters is our advice segment
so if you ever want to write us in
all of these submissions are from our
listeners it's deartoasters gmail.com
we'll always keep it anonymous and you
can change people's names if you want to
and you can really write in about
anything today we have quite a robust
group of submissions let's just dive
right in i'm getting to that point in
the show where i'm like
starting to slur my words because i'm so
tired do you need water
um you know what sure like let's hydrate
this is actually a long episode we don't
really do episodes this long
okay i feel better hi jackie and claudia
love you gals let's dive right in
recently my ex-boyfriend started dating
my current boyfriend's sister
and it's getting very serious i've tried
to let it go but i simply cannot it's
really eating me up and i don't know
what to do
let me hit you with all the facts i
dated the ex for about a year with while
my current boyfriend and i were taking
some time apart
the two guys obviously hate each other
and almost got into a fight before
my ex is also the type of guy who
constantly reached out after a breakup
to tell me he'd always love me and be
there for me
i live with my boyfriend and i'm
extremely close with his family we have
dinner together at least three nights a
week
the sister has stopped participating in
family events
completely which makes me think that
she's avoiding me she introduced him to
their mom and i've heard through the
grapevine he'll be at thanksgiving
how do i handle this i'm in such a happy
place in my relationship and his family
treats me like their own
i feel like my ex dating my future
sister-in-law is really threatening that
i'm so angry i think i might explode
during thanksgiving thanks for the any
advice you have to give
a very stressed toaster that's horrible
that is really hard but what you have to
do and the only thing you can do
is take the high road if you do anything
other than that you will
regret it if you exploded thanksgiving
like the only person who will look bad
is you you just have if you are so happy
with your
current boyfriend like just ride that
out like enjoy the joy there and just
ignore the rest of it
if the sister and the ex-boyfriend are
otp meant to be then like that's
beautiful for them i don't think that
that's the case i think that they
are all trying to ruffle your feathers
but the worst thing you can do when
someone is trying to ruffle your
feathers is let your feathers be ruffled
yeah you know i'm i'm thinking about
this and i'm trying to think
like who can i who can i place blame on
like who can i be mad at
and you know now that i think about it
it's extremely uncool of the sister
like for this ex-boyfriend he's like
just dating a girl he doesn't care like
he doesn't owe anyone anything but like
the sister owes it to her brother and
his girlfriend like to be respectful and
not like date her ex you know
i think it's very uncool of her i think
that this ex is clearly
very like kind of crazy
maybe and he what he does can't be
predicted but if the sister is like a
nice sister then
what she does can me so and like she
could
act better so unless like this is like
true love and you're standing in the way
um just let it play out because you know
what
even like spite relationships run their
course
yes blac chyna and rob right so just
patience
is key take the high road and jackie
said it best
someone's trying to ruffle your feathers
the best thing you can do is just to not
like be unbothered not let your feathers
get rough
don't give them exactly what they want
because if thanksgiving goes smoothly
and you're unbothered and it's so clear
you're happy in your relationship and
you don't care about
your ex enough to even care what he's
doing like he will grow tired
and he will probably if it's not a real
relationship he will exit the scene
shortly thereafter if like if you don't
give him what he's looking for like
please just stay steady
yeah and just like ignore ignore ignore
shrug it off shrug it off
um that would make me so angry i'm
trying to think like because the
opposite of love is not hate it is
indifferent it's so true
so you being hateful just shows him that
you're closer to love
than indifference so if you're
indifferent right
i'm trying to think of like that would
be like i mean i don't really have any
ex-boyfriends like one of them dating
ben's sister right yeah that would be
very strange
yeah and make me definitely
uncomfortable not angry but
uncomfortable
yeah well good luck to you next up
dear toasters i read his diary yes you
read that right
my boyfriend and i have been long
distance for a year and a half he went
to a wedding last weekend and then came
to visit me
when we were together we went to get gas
and while he was at a pump i noticed a
journal on the ground
i couldn't help myself and i picked it
up and opened it to the last entry
long story short it said they say when
you know you know i wonder if that's
true i've been putting up walls and have
been complacent and inconsiderate
i want true love i want what blank and
blank people in the wedding he went to
i want what they have i confronted him
about it and apologize for reading it
but overall i decided i wanted to break
up with him
if he doesn't know then i don't want to
waste his time because i thought i knew
he was the one for me
he begged me to give him a chance to
open up and be more vulnerable with him
and to put more effort in our
relationship
because he respects me and can see a
future with me aka he would break up
with me if he didn't see it
we are still together but i can't stop
replaying the words in my head what do
you think i'm 26 turning
he just turned 27 how long should i wait
for him to realize i'm the one i really
do love this guy
sincerely a toaster and a redhead oh
right
yes she's obviously like a well-read
genius with a great taste in pots
podcasts
i just want to say because i need to say
this like i really don't condone you
reading history i know you were gonna
have
i like i don't know i just think that
everyone deserves
uh like a piece of privacy and for a lot
of people like that's their phones and
like so you don't snoop
but you do if you have like well-founded
suspicions
i just think that reading someone's
diary is like
so wrong we've spoken about this before
and i think you would tell
her to break up with him because he even
keeps a diary yeah no oh my god i'm
actually traumatized i cannot speak on
men who keep diaries because i'm
traumatized because because of what you
did
what i did yeah when we were in
nashville um we were uh
we did a like a week of shows in
nashville around cma fest like three
years ago
and we were in this studio and we hired
like all these freelance um like
videographers camera guys av and they
were so nice and cool and like we like
really had created like a bond with them
over the over the week
and on one of the last days we were
doing like a dear uh
brothers to your toasters no olivia
cready was on and she was talking about
how her the man that she was seeing had
a diary and should she read it
oh oh oh and i just like went off about
like
men who who write diaries are sissies
and it's weird and
i was just like railing on just like the
male species having diaries
and i was like saying to the camera guys
i'm like you guys don't have diaries
right and this one guy was like no i do
i journal every day
and i was like that's
beautiful so i don't really i stay out
of the journaling conversation now since
i offended an entire
gender um so maybe you just take this
one
so okay honestly i'm surprised that
after you read his diary and his
innermost
thoughts were exposed which were like
not sure about you that he
even like wanted to stay together he
would be he should be mad so like this
is obviously an extremely mature
person and i don't know i feel
i feel two types of ways because i feel
like on the one hand sometimes when
someone like doesn't know and
how long did they say how long they had
been together no like sometimes oh yes a
year and a half but they're long
distance
oh that's really tough like sometimes a
year and a half like is enough to know
that you don't know and and that means
that you know that it's wrong right like
the fact that it's been a year and a
half and like you really know and like
he's the one and he just like can't
decide it's like you want to be with
someone who like wants to be with you
and you
you want to be wanted yeah i agree but
can i just say
the fact that like he is unsure but he's
the one who's fighting for the
relationship and for you to give him
another chance like
i don't know i think that there's
something that could be there i really
do
i just wait now that he's like not
willing to let you go it means that like
you probably are the one but like i just
it doesn't feel nice that like it's
taking him so long to figure it out
but i also feel like it's kind of like
when you're in a
in an investigation or like a court
procedure when you get when you gather
evidence illegally like
it is stricken from the record it
doesn't count right and so i don't think
that like
you should know his inner like people's
innermost thoughts like
you know that they would share with only
themselves in their diary like are not
there's a reason why it's prime and
there's a reason why
he doesn't say it to you and that's why
i don't like when people read someone
else's diary because
we are all entitled to our thoughts i i
totally agree and so that's why i want
to strike his diary from the record
because
it also was right after a wedding like
this is one diary entry where he had
a like he saw a beautiful love
relationship and just questioned what he
had for a second like
that he didn't say it to you like he
didn't make it permanent
it was for him no you're right it's
people are entitled to their own
thoughts and if we don't have our
thoughts what do we have
and so i feel like the diary is
evidence that was acquired without a
warrant and it should be struggling from
the record and now evaluate your
relationship for the past
inadmissible are you happy it's
inadmissible it's inadmissible
i want to say something really quickly
about journaling i just want to like go
on the record because the last time i
spoke about journaling specifically as
it pertains to men like i roasted them
and that was like four years ago and i
feel like i've actually really changed
my stance on that and i just want to put
it on the record because normalize
changing your opinions based on new
information
um now that i have
marinated with it and i'm in a much more
mature place in my life i
actually really respect men who journal
and i'm not just saying this like
make up for like me literally being so
mean um
but it's like when i was watching mad
men when
don is in this like really dark place in
his life and then he decides to get his
life together and he
starts swimming every morning and he
starts journaling and it's just like
writing random things about his feeling
it's actually like a deeply mature and
introspective thing to be able to do and
like i don't i've never journaled and i
don't know if i'm
willing to be that insightful but from
honest with yourself for like a man to
do it i don't know it's actually very
impressive i wish ben would journal i do
i wish
he was that you know sensitive yeah but
ben can't journal because he knows that
you'll read it
100 and it's like if i knew that my
husband journaled
it would be really hard for me not to
read it of course but
i would try every day to not i know i
would like fully read it every night
yeah no i but i would never bring it up
i just would like want to know like what
he's thinking
and it's not because i'm malicious
because i love him so much i just want
to know everything but what if you saw
stuff in there that like
was hard for you to accept like like
that was stuff about you
and you know well he would obviously
like not be able to write anything about
me in the journal that would be the rule
i'd be like i would say
i won't read your journal you just can't
write anything about me and then i would
read every night to make sure he's
following the rules
okay but again you didn't follow the
rules but he doesn't need to know
because i will never bring it up to him
but it might affect how you behave you
treat him no no i can i can fake it
okay um okay final one hi claudia jackie
and doctor theodore for chemin
hi thrill i'm hoping for some premium
premium advice on my problem my husband
and i have another couple we are very
close with it's been a few years since
we all became friends and i've just been
trying
my hardest to like the wife of my
husband's friend but i just don't
i've come to the conclusion that she is
either obsessed with me or is beyond
insecure
she asked me where all my clothes are
from and even what size they are
anything that i've mentioned i want
purse plants etc she immediately goes
out and buys it oh my god that's so
for herself yeah every time i go over to
their house she has to take me on a tour
of
everything she's bought recently and i
just don't care i've mentioned this to
my husband
but i feel badly because he's so close
with his friend and they always want us
to hang out as a foursome
i say no to plants from time to time
because it takes a lot of energy to hang
out with the wife and i just don't
always have it
it's clear that these people aren't
going away so how do i help this chick
to be less obsessed with me sincerely
what the [ __ ] do i do
to be honest this is like a real problem
being a couple like
because you have couple friends and it's
like you either like are in it because
the wife is friends with the wife and
like the husband stinks or you're
friends with it because the husband's
friends the husbands and then the wife
stings it's like
it's very rare that you find a couple
where it's like you like the husband and
the wife
just as much um and it makes like double
dating awkward and it makes like growing
up like and being friends and
then like being married friends it makes
it just this is something to change
but particularly with with this girl
it's there's
nothing more annoying than a girl who
like oh i like blue cargo pants and like
literally the next day shows up
blue carpet pants pretending like it was
her idea like yeah someone who lacks
creativity and like original ideas and
style and like doesn't own it
yeah you know no i agree i think the
solution here is like
one obviously just be clear with your
husband like these aren't like she's not
your people but you'll support him when
necessary and two like
maybe just go out for dinner so you're
not having to go to their house and like
see all of her new things like
if you can or do double dates that are
activities
where everyone's distracted busy so that
you're not like stuck
listening to her but sometimes you just
gotta take one for the team but also
maybe work on fostering couple
friendships that might take your husband
away from this friendship
you just have to be like if you're it's
just like criticism like or
when you say something negative like
don't do just something negative like
also
give an option for a better yeah
solution you know so you have to tell
your husband like i'll continue to do
this but like
just be mindful that i'm not having a
good time so like when it's time to
leave like let's go like
if your husband's like dragging it out
because he's having a great time with
his friend drinking beer watching
football being like
no no when we say we're leaving at eight
like you come get me at eight like i'll
do this for you
you do that for me yeah it's a
compromise that's what marriage is yeah
but this is not sustainable so um just
then the the double the foursome is
gonna suffer you know yeah you can't say
anything to the wife
because at the end of the day she's just
trying to like impress you yeah she's
not me and she's just
annoying he can still be friends with
his friend like and you don't have to go
i think that that's fine it's a guy's
night yeah it sounds fun
sounds wonderful gino gino just make
some other couple friends so like your
social events calendar is like so busy
with clan bakes trips to the cape
that you can't literally fit in time for
this couple maybe once a month now maybe
just a dinner two hours tops maybe the
table
that's the thing it's like when you're
going out to dinner like time is of the
essence
yeah but also like she can't show you
her new closet of all the things that
were your idea her new plant
yeah you should probably start taking
pictures of them and show you them at
dinner
also like if you just want to be a
little petty why don't you like say you
want something that's like
really ugly and then she'll start
wearing that and then you can have the
last laugh also if you want to be petty
like stop sharing things with her like
what you want just keep that information
to yourself no or just share like bad
bad really expensive things be like i've
been saving up for this like corduroy
over these like swarovski crocs
that's good yeah that's actually good
advice um so again that was your
toasters thank you guys for
submitting and trusting us with your
qualms and quandaries and if you ever
want to write in the email to email us
is dear toasters gmail.com i actually
think crocs get a really bad rap and i
absolutely love them agreed i wear them
almost every day
i just want to retract what i said
because they're dropping fire collapse
justin bieber luke comes maybe a
swarovski messenger back
yeah like a squat no like like yeah
yeah no i actually love crocs like we
wear crocs and i think
like it really bothers me when other
people talk about them like as the
ugliest it's like the go-to
juggly thing but like i don't think that
like i think that they have so much
value and i don't want to pile on
no and it's like whether you're wearing
them in the summer or now they make ones
with fur inside like they're literally
perfect they're giving auger one for
their money i said it yeah
no i totally agree and you know what i
think they make your legs look skinny i
said it oh you said it too
ben wears them every single day there's
a pair of crocs outside my door
for when we walk through four times a
day almost every day um
i saw um i saw a friend last week she
was wearing fur crocs like they're
taking over manhattan i'm just saying
no i i absolutely love to see it justice
for crocs
j4c thank you guys so much for listening
to the morning toast the millennial
morning show where we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know every
morning monday through friday on youtube
so if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
heart radio cast box all the places
so ever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning toast leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are
we hope you have an amazing day happy
hump day hump someone you love and we
will see you tomorrow for thursday's
show
[Music]
goodbye